hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing with the
1858 match between paul charles morphy
and daniel harvest and so far
uh morphe is not doing all that great in
the match but if you've seen the
previous video you know that morphe won
the first
game of the match but even though uh he
lost the the first game they played the
before the match even started and the uh
game one and two of the match morphe
wasn't really all that worried and he
did uh
claim uh that harvest will not win a
single game so in the previous game it
was a pretty pretty good fight
harvest fought back very hard and morphe
was able to win this
but this one it's uh also a very
enjoyable one
so let's check it out and see if morphe
can
uh you know keep true to his uh promise
that harvests will not win a single
game and before we check it out uh there
is just something i wanted to show you a
subscriber sent me this it's um
uh well it's sort of a deep learning uh
reconstructed image of paul morphy but
rather not an image but
made into a video so sort of a video of
paul morphy
made constructed from one of his photos
i i think there's not a lot of them but
uh well here it is so let's just enjoy
that for a few seconds and and
let me know what you guys think so it's
pretty pretty cool that
they're able to do this i like to to
make the photo come alive so yeah there
it is
let me just check that so there's paul
morphy and you can see
uh the ai made it so that that morphe
can move his head
you know look around i think there's
even a smile there at the end so that's
also very cool
uh i don't know i'm gonna replay it uh
so let's just check it out again
i mean there's so many things you can do
with
technology like this it's uh i mean it
it's just insane that we can have uh
such a a wonderful wonderful uh
almost a high resolution video of paul
charles murphy
but i hope you guys enjoyed it let me
let me know what you think uh and it's
uh
really really awesome that uh we we live
in uh you know
uh the day and age when when such things
are possible but getting back
to this game uh paul morphy versus
daniel harvest morphe with the white
pieces and he opens with
e4 as he usually does sorry about that
uh we have e5 by harvest uh and now
knight to f3 so morphe repeats what he
tried in the first game we have d6
going for the affiliators defense we
have d4 e captures and e4
and now queen captures on d4 we have
knight to c6
attacking morphy's queen and bishop to
b5 now pinning the knight
bishop to d7 we have captures captures
sorry cap
wow captures captures and now bishop to
g5 so everything this
uh exactly the same as in game one only
in that game harvest defended with
knight to f6 but here he tries
f6 and this is where we deviate from
game one uh that as you know harvest one
so morphe's bishop is under attack he
needs to move it with bishop to h4
and now knight to h6 sort of a different
way to
develop her pieces but then later on the
knight is coming to f7 and then to e5
and it's going to be a very nice outpost
for this knight
we have knight to c3 and here this
position has been reached a few times
but in every game
bishop the e7 was played however uh here
harvard's played queen to d7
and it is as of move 9 that this
position has never been reached again
uh so let's see how morphy continues
here here morphe castles king's side
you could also consider castling
queenside i i guess maybe morphy wanted
to avoid both of them castle in
queenside because he wanted to attack
but it's uh it's definitely possible
because for the moment castling queen
side is impossible because of queen
captures on a7
but okay morphe probably had his reasons
for deciding to
uh castle king side both are very much
possible
uh we have bishop to e7 and now rook
eight to d1
uh morphe is continuing development we
have castles also
uh kingside castles and now queen to c4
uh this comes with check and now for
some reason harvest doesn't go king to
h8 he goes
rook to f7 uh he wants to bring the
other rook to f8 so he kind of
moves the rook to f7 with tempo uh and
then later on he wants to play g5 play
rook to g7 and so on so a very very
elaborate plan
we have knights to d4 now preparing to
uh to get this knight over to e6 and
here this uh will be a monster knight
and now
knight the g4 again the knight wants to
come to e5 like we mentioned but also
it's uh it's a very tricky piece for
example you could
very easily blunder the game if you play
something like f4 and then all of a
sudden you face this monster fork here
uh morphe of course not interested in
such things he just kicks away the
knight
knight to e5 attacking the queen and now
queen back to e2
so for the moment you don't get to
create any monster knights here on e6
we have g5 now uh not really worried
about uh weakening his king side
as he feels he has all the compensation
needed we have bishop to g3 and now
rook to g7 uh we have knight to f5 now
by morphe putting pressure on the rook
here and
rook to g6 and here morphe strikes
immediately with
f4 so the knight is under attack uh g
captures on f4 and now rook captures on
f4 morphy wants to play rook to h5
queen rook to h4 queen to h5 and go for
some checkmating ideas
so king to h8 preparing to bring the
other rook into the game as well
we have rook to h4 and now as there's
going to be a lot of pressure along this
h-file bishop to f8 now the queen will
help out with the defense of the h7 pawn
uh and morphe decides to eliminate the
knight from e5 this is an extremely
strong knight and for the moment
morphy's bishop not really doing all
that much you could
try and maybe activate it with bishop to
f4 but for the moment it's only a target
here on g3 so morbid morphe decides to
eliminate
the knight with bishop captures on e5
now the d-pawn cannot capture the rook
is still on d1 so
f captures on e5 is a must and now rook
to f1
now morphy shifts the other rook into
the attack as well we have queen to e6
uh and now comes uh well queen to e6
probably with the idea that if
queen h5 threatening checkmate queen to
g8 the defending checkmate and also
threatening rook to g1 so
kind of a kind of a counter attacking
move so here after queen to e6 we have
knight to b5 by morphe going after
this c7 pawn which will attack the queen
and the rook
uh and here while you don't have to
capture it you could just to defend it
uh or or try some sort of uh some sort
of
an idea to play passively uh harvest
decides to go uh
actively about it he immediately goes
queen to g8 puts a pressure on g2 for
the moment the queen defends it so uh
there isn't any threat and he allows uh
morphy to kind of go after the the c7
pawn but morphy is in no rush murphy
just plays rook to f2
now uh bishop captures queen captures is
possible because the rook is also
guarding the g2 pawn
and now a6 harvest now insists that
morphe captures on c7
which morphe does with root cap knight
captures in c7
and now rook to c8 we have knights back
to d5 and here
bishop captures on d5 with e captures on
d5
and here lies the problem of a harvest
position
uh the d5 pawn is not free for grabs the
problem with
queen cactus and d5 is that nothing is
defending the h7 pawn here rook captures
an h7 just wins the game for morphe and
that was uh
the base of morphe's attack for example
king captures
queen to h5 with check bishop to h6
blocking
and now knight to e7 with this monster
fork here
and it doesn't matter what you do once
you go back queen to e6 you're just
going to play knight
captures and let's say queen captures
just rook to f7 with
check so not much to do here you have to
block
queen to g7 or you can even go up the
board and then lose the queen
so that's also possible but let's say
queen g5 and now this queen to f5 check
just ends the game you don't even have
to capture the queen right away
king j8 captures with check for example
queen captures here and it's a
completely winning position for white so
instead after he captures
and the five harvests uh realizes that
this is impossible and he plays
rook to c7 a very strong defensive move
adds a defender here
now prepares queen captures on d5 but
such
things are no longer possible morphe
immediately plays c4 uh cements that
pawn on d5
and now what do you do here uh well the
fact of the matter is that black is
without a good move
there are no good moves with the rook
there are no good moves with the bishop
the queen and rook battery and the g
file isn't really doing all that much
and it seems that our good friend
harvest here
is uh well left without any options he
can just wait and see what morphe will
do
and usually when such a position occurs
uh you know
at some point one one move will be too
many to hold everything
so here bishop to e7 awaiting move uh
checking to see what morphe does okay
it's an active move attacking the rogue
but
basically it's still an uh a waiting
move
uh rook the h5 by morphe and now while
you could go back with bishop to f8 and
try repeating we have queen the e8
harvest tries to play actively
from a position that does not allow such
things so uh feel free to pause the
video here
and punish our good friend daniel
harvest for his insolence
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not sacrificing the rook right away that
doesn't work
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's c5
but uh come up with a move like c5 you
first have to
try and sacrifice the rook on h7 i hope
all of you tried sacrificing the rook on
h7 in your mind
because only by trying to sacrifice the
rook on h7 do we
get the idea of playing c5 because uh
after rook captures king captures and
queen to h5
check king the g8 you now realize that
you don't have a good move here
because after knight captures here uh
you just play rook captures and the
queen keeps defending the rook here
and if you don't capture on e7 there's
really nothing to do you can just go for
a perpetual knight
checking here knight checking here
knight to check for example so the idea
behind
this amazing c5 move is actually to get
the rook away from the defense of the h7
pawn and this is this is beautiful stuff
so here uh rook captures on c5 was
played you might think but why play this
when you don't have to well
there isn't a better move uh for example
if you go d captures on c5
queen capture sun e5 ends the game on
the spot you just lose the rook and
rook on c7 and that's it and that's not
even the worst part the worst part is
that your
bishop is under attack now there's no
way to defend it you can't move the
bishop because queen captures on h7 so
obviously d captures on c5 is not
not even an option after c5 another
thing you could do
is uh completely disregard this pawn
play a passive room something like rook
to d7 because you have to keep an eye on
the h7 pawn
but then morphe would just slowly keep
improving his position b
for a4 b5 and you know completely
crushed black
black on the queen side uh as black
really has no active moves
so here after the c5 move uh harvard
decided to capture the pawn he played
rook captures on c5
but now your first inclination rook
captures on h7 is possible and
this is what morphe played here rook
captures on h7
with check king captures now queen to h5
with
check king to g8 and now of course
knight captures on e7
now the rook is no longer on c7 to
defend the
uh the knight uh to the to to be able to
capture back
on e7 and here uh of course queen
captures is impossible then it's
just queen captures and g6 check and
that's it king g7 you're gonna play
queen the e6 check
king h7 and now rook f5 threatening uh
this beautiful rook h5 check so after
queen g6
you're gonna play rook f7 check and
after this just win
win black's queen so that's one way to
do it but any uh any way you play this
is a completely lost if you capture the
knight so here harvest played king to g7
instead but now morphy just goes knight
to f5 check
we have king to g8 and here morphy plays
knight captures on d6 and this is just
uh
completely crushing uh because the rook
cannot capture the knight
the queen would be hanging here and
there are no more uh squares left
all of these squares are covered by the
knight this square is covered by the
pawn so that means the black queen can
no longer
keep defending the uh the
rook and g6 here and there is one more
thing you could attempt and that of
course is uh
rook captures on g2 with check thinking
that oh yes i'm gonna win morphy's queen
the problem is
rook g2 comes also with check so
that obviously doesn't work and you're
you're just getting checkmated king here
queen captures will be checkmate so here
after morphy played this knight captures
on d6
uh it was in this position on move 35
that daniel harvest resigned to the game
as there is definitely nothing more he
can do here
uh so yeah morphy equalizes the score it
is now 2-2 morphe lost
the first two games but then he came
back uh with in great style winning game
three and game four
and uh uh he's still able to to keep his
word uh as
harvest did not win a single game after
murphy said it
after his loss in game two so we'll see
if morphe can keep it up
uh and how the match will turn out uh so
really really amazing stuff i hope you
guys enjoyed it i would like to thank
jill well dearest uh john raul
dominic contoir uh ben webb and brandon
wade for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching
and i will see you soon uh continuing
the coverage of the morphe saga checking
up on your wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day and
let's check out morphy's
footage one more time for the end of
this video
see you soon